how would you build a life meter let's
say we're together starting new company
launching a life me mass spectrometer
would be the first way of doing it just
take no no no but that's that's um
that's one of the major components of it
but I'm talking about like what if it's
a device we got to and and branding logo
we got to talk that that's later but
what's the input what's the like how do
you get to the um a metered output so I
would I would take a life so my my life
meter our life meter there you go thank
you yeah you're
welcome um uh would have both infrared
and MPC so it would have two ports so it
could shine a light um and so what it
would do is you would have a a vacuum
chamber and you'd have an electrostatic
analyzer and you'd have a monochromator
to producing infrared um you'd add the
samp so you'd take a scoop of the sample
put it in the Life meter it would then
add a solvent or heat up the sample so
some volatiles come off the volatiles
would then be put into the into the mass
spectromet into electrostatic trap and
you'd weigh the molecules and fragment
them alternatively you'd shine infrared
light on them you count the number of
bands but you'd have to in that case do
some separation because you want to
separate in and so in MPC it's really
nice and convenient because you can
separate electrostatically but um you
need to have that can you do it in real
time yeah pretty much pretty much yeah
so let's go all the way back so okay
we're really get this the the Lex's life
me Lex and Lee's life Lex and Lee it's a
good it's a good good uh good ring to it
all right so um you have a you have a
vacuum chamber you have a little nose
the nose would have um some a a a
packing material so you would take your
your sample add it onto the nose add a
solvent or a gas it would then be sucked
up the nose and that would be separated
using Chrome what we call chromatography
and then as each band comes off the NOS
we would then do mck and infrared and in
the count in the case of infrared count
the number of bands in the case of mck
count the number of fragments and weigh
it and then the further up in molecular
weight range for the mass spec and the
number of bands you go up and up and up
from the you know dead interesting
interesting over the threshold oh my
gosh Earth life and then right up to bat
crazy this is definitely um you
know alien intelligence that's made this
life right you could almost go all the
way there same in the infrared and
pretty simple the thing that is really
problematical is that for many years
decades what people have done and I
can't blame them is they've rather
they've been obsessing about small
biomarkers on that we find on Earth
amino acids like single amino acids or
evidence of small molecules and these
things and looking for those run looking
for complexity there the beauty
beautiful thing about this is you can
look for um complexity without Earth
Earth chemistry bias or Earth biology
bias so assembly theory is just a way of
saying hey complexity and abundance is
evidence selection that's how our
universal life meter will
work